this one's from Peter in San Francisco
he writes the sex nudity violence and
gore in the HBO series so continuing
with our previous question has has been
very much like the books that preserved
a similar feel could you please discuss
the creative process around the
inclusion of this mature content was
there any pressure to tone it up or down
well of course there was no pressure on
me because I'm hardly involved I mean
I'm I am basically a consultant and who
writes one episode per season and so
whether there was pressure on Dan and
Dave to go one way another I really
don't know if so they didn't share it
with me you know we did make some
decisions early on that we wanted to
include that material and the the
biggest one is where we took the show
where when Dan and and Dave and I
decided to that we would do this project
together and I attached them we
discussed this at some length and said
well you know we have to go HBO was our
first choice and pretty much our only
choice if if HBO had said no or they
weren't interested yeah we could have
gone to another couple of our cable
outlets but I think we were all greed
right from the beginning that we weren't
gonna go to the traditional networks ABC
or CBS or NBC or any of those simply
because they would have made us remove
all of that material away everything
would have been gone and you know much
toned down violence no sex whatsoever
we're just sort of a few hints of sex
and certainly no inappropriate sex and
you know a fantasy series they would
have slotted us as an eight o'clock show
I mean I've been through this in my in
my Hollywood years I worked ten years in
Hollywood from the mid 80s to the mid
90s and I worked on a couple shows
Twilight Zone the The Twilight Zone
revival and beauty and a beast both of
which were eight o'clock shows you know
despite the fact on both shows we kept
saying we don't want to be an eight
o'clock show we want to be like a nine
o'clock or a 10 o'clock show because
there's standards and practices
sensors and things are a little looser
there and you could do a little more
material and and you know the network
guys would promise us oh well we know
that way we really think of you as an
adult show not a kiddie show but you
know we have no room on a schedule so
we'll well put you as an 8 o'clock show
but we'll treat you as a 9 o'clock show
and then we would be put as an 8 o'clock
show and and those guys who were the
programming guys would suddenly no
longer be around and instead we'd be
dealing with standards and practices
guys who were censors who were saying I
don't care what programming told you
you're an 8 o'clock show and these are
our eight o'clock standards so we made a
decision right away we're gonna go with
HBO HBO has that kind of stuff whether
it's a 7 o'clock show an 8 o'clock show
a 5:30 show they don't care you know
you're signing up for HBO you're paying
a subscription you know what you're
getting and what you're getting is
something you can't get on the over the
year networks so that's that's part of
it and then the other big decision we
have to make to keep all that material
was the ages of the characters you know
in the books Danny is 13 years old when
when all this begins and I was drawing
although my books are fantasy they're
not historical fiction in a strict sense
they occur in imaginary world and and
imaginary kingdoms they're very heavily
based on real medieval history and of
course I've done a ton of research about
real medieval history and you know
basically in the Middle Ages they did
not have our concept of adolescence of
this sort of teenage year in-between
where we're kind of adults but we're not
adults and we have different ages where
you know we're allowed to vote at this
age and we're allowed to go to war and
die at a different age and we're allowed
to drink at another age and to have sex
at a different age depending on which
state were in
all of that stuff they had child and
adult and the difference between them
was the onset of sexual maturity and we
still have in our culture's remnants of
this older structure in our ceremonies
the Jewish Bar Mitzvah the Catholic
confirmation ceremony which I went
through is 13 you know reaffirming as an
adult the the vows made for me by my
godparents at baptism you know that's
that the Catholics once considered 13
adulthood and I promise you that even at
when I went through my confirmation
ceremony my parents no longer considered
did not consider me an adult even
afterwards that I wanted to write a
passage so you know these things are
just remnants now but they weren't
remnants in the Middle Ages and they're
they're not in the books we have a very
different way of looking at things so I
was using that based on historical
precedent but there was no way that was
gonna fly in our present environment we
couldn't do that if we had cast a
13-year old Danny there could have been
no sexual stuffs whatsoever with with
her and even if we had cast even if we
had cast like a 17 year actress playing
a 13 year olds there are some very
stringent laws in like the United
Kingdom you can't you can't do that even
if you have a an actress who's passed
the age of consent playing someone who's
under the age of consent you you cannot
have a sexual situation because it gets
the old child pornography thing and
stuff like that so we have a 22 year old
actress playing a 17 year old Danny
instead of a 17 year old actress playing
a 13 year old Danny and you know we did
that deliberately to so we could include
this material so I think that speaks to
the fact that we did think it was
necessary to the story we wanted to tell
and all that of course once you make
that change then you have to make all of
the other changes and you have to age up
the other characters because Danny's
birth to the you know she was born
posthumously on nine months after the
Battle of Detroit and the fall of King's
Landing and
so the character ages the other
characters has to be adjusted
accordingly and it becomes a whole you
know once again the butterfly effect and
so the whole thing is a tapestry and you
can't just change one string without the
whole thing unraveling so Dan and David
made this whole series of changes but a
long answer to a short question I guess
good a good answer though